- What's new on Love Life this season?
I was just telling you
in the break, Patricia,
my sister is obsessed.
She watched it all in one day.
- Well, it's funny because can I say,
just in-between right now
that you know, there's,
they're playing the clip
and I'm genuinely going to,
no, this new season is so good, which,
I feel like I can say,
cause I'm in the show this season,
but, I'm not the lead, and William Jackson
Harper from, he's Chidi on the good place.
He's so amazing.
(audience cheers)
He's the lead of this season.
And he is so good in it.
And the new season is so good.
And it's one of those things where,
the first season, you know,
I was the lead of the first season and
it was, a lot of it was mined
from my personal life--
- Like real? Personal--
- Like real personal life where,
we changed enough details that,
I wouldn't get angry phone calls.
Hopefully.
- I think people wish
I'd do that with songs.
(Kelly and Anna laugh)
- Whoops!
Sorry!
- [Kelly] Sorry!
- Shouldn't have messed up.
- [Kelly] Truth.
- Then you wouldn't be in a song.
- Not my fault.
- But the second season,
it's one of those funny things where,
even though it's about
a guy who's a different
race, different gender,
different point in his life.
It starts with him, unlike my season,
it starts with him in his thirties
and his life blows up.
Relatable.
And then it's sort of,
oh, I'm starting over.
I thought my- I found my person,
but instead, I'm on a love life journey--
- This is so unrelatable!
- I know!
How would anyone--
- Says who would relate to this?
- And it's, but you know,
the Olivia Rodrigo stuff of, oh my gosh,
you can be 17 and feeling
all the same stuff.
And then, you know, this new season is,
is, you're a grown person,
but you're still humiliating
yourself for love.
And you know, just you're moping around
when your heart is broken--
- I'd rather be that person than Jaden.
I'd rather humiliate myself--
- Totally!
- Absolutely run into the humiliation.
- Run, just head on.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's really the message--
- That's my advice--
- This new season, yeah.
- That's the tagline.
- Run towards humiliation,
Love Life Season 2.
(Kelly Laughs)
- When we've talked about this before,
but you started acting
when you were pretty young.
Right?
- Yeah.
- I kind of heard crazy
stories of how you used to be
young and traveled to New
York, without parents.
- Yeah.
So I grew up in Maine and I started
auditioning for Broadway shows and stuff
when I was 10 and around, and basically
that would mean my
parents have to drive me
five hours to New York
for one audition and then
come home, which was just not sustainable.
You know, they both worked full time.
And so eventually around 12,
my brother was 14 and they were like,
"You guys can get on a
Greyhound bus and go to
New York City and come
back and you'll be fine."
- Not a Dateline special
in the way they talked.
- [Anna] Yeah!
- Yeah, no.
- But yeah.
So when I went and
auditioned for High Society,
which was the show that I eventually did,
they, you know, I get on a Greyhound bus
with my brother, I audition.
and they're like, "Okay. So we want to
call you back for tomorrow."
Very exciting.
And they were like, "So
we'll see you tomorrow."
And I was like, "Yes, you will.
Because I live here."
Totally.
(Kelly Laughs)
Absolutely.
I am not a homeless street rat,
running around the streets of New York.
So my parents
faxed a credit card,
a copy of the credit card to a hotel.
And they were, our children will be
checking in and then
we'll be along shortly
because obviously we're
not terrible parents
who've let them go to New York.
- Oh my gosh I love your parents.
- And so we know walk
in and we're like, "Yes,
our parents will be along shortly." And--
- It's clearly--
- And we like wash our socks
and underwear in the sink.
And then, just go back in the next day.
And just all the while pretending, yes,
I am a totally normal
person who lives here
and I'm not--
(Kelly Laughs)
- I just came from my home.
Your brother's awesome
to take you to do that.
It's so cool.
- Yeah
- Yeah, we're having a
(indistinct) for my brother.
- That's so, and I mean,
it's just so funny.
Cause when you have kids,
I'm going to ask you
if you would allow your
kid, because I would
never allow my kids to
do what I did when I
was young.
It was like, "Oh just
be home before dark."
- Oh, I wouldn't even allow
my kids to be sick on me
- the way that you that you would so...
- I know.
You would.
- So maybe I'd be the kind of person who
would be like, "Have fun sweetie!
Bye!
Good Luck!"
(Kelly laughs)
- That's amazing
"Don't talk to strangers!"
So wait, you tweeted this a while ago,
but I love superhero movies as well.
So I have to ask about it.
You wrote "In movies,
when the super villain
tells his origin story
I honestly get worried
because I relate so hard."
- True.
- I love this.
I love the backstory.
The new Cruella?
- Oh Yeah. Oh Yeah.
How did they get here?
Because the whole movie
they're doing these
terrible things and
you're, oh yeah, awful.
But then, there's a point in the third act
when they're like, "I was
different as a child."
And you're like, "Oh no."
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah
- They're like, "I was
always envious of the
other girls that I was nothing like them"
- "My parents were horrible to me"
- "They sent me to New York
on a Greyhound bus and--"
What?
(Kelly laughs)
- They abandoned you?
- Wait. This is very specific.
"I was small and I wouldn't stop singing."
Wait, no.
(Kelly laughs)
They is very specifically about me now.
No, but I always feel, well, this is,
I feel very close to the villains.
- I love that.
And you're lovely.
So I'm not worried.
Cause my daughter, her favorite
character is the villains.
She loves Ursula, not little mermaid.
- [Anna] Yeah!
- She's got the better song.
- It's true.
Let's be real.
It is the better song.
But you're really awesome.
So now, the foreshadowing is nice.
- Yeah.
She's going to turn out to be me,
which is shrill, but mostly fun.
- Yeah.
That's kind of similar to me, actually.
- Great!
- Not too far off the mark.
And then there's this post though.
"There must be so much
elevator security cam
footage of me with headphones
on, where I get in,
wait for the doors to
close, and then immediately
bust a move like I'm
headlining Coachella."
(Kelly laughs)
Which, you're so funny.
- But is that not true?
- I am also one of these people that
gets in and it's just, whoa!
- Yeah, the second door's closed, it's a
private concert for millions of fans--
- That are totally tuned in.
- Oh they are like, they're
like "Anna, you're incredible".
- Amazing.
Yeah.
(audience claps)
Well I brought it up because, well,
you rode our elevator this morning,
so, let's just see what happened.
Let's see.
♪ Forever ♪
♪ You make me ♪
- [Anna] Is this a, is this a--
♪ Feel like I'm livin' a teenage dream ♪
- [Anna] This is amazing.
(Anna laughs)
♪ The way you turn me on, I can't sleep ♪
♪ Let's run away-- ♪
(elevator beeps)
♪ Don't ever look back, yeah ♪
♪ (elevator beeps) ♪
♪ My heart stops ♪
(indistinct conversation)
(audience cheers)
- I look at that and I
go, yeah, I should be.
I should be headlining Coachella.
- You should be headlining Coachella.
- Really.
- Yes.
I think this is a dream
we need to see happen.
She agrees.